[Music]  this is a hell of a predicament we'll  find ourselves in I used to be a  Salesman I could read people now I'd  like to take a stab at selling you  judging by the brokedown car and the  sorry state of my front door I'd say  both of you are on the lam how'd I do  that was amazing I feel like I might be  able to read people just like that I'm  gonna try right now your clothes look  expensive and this is a pretty house but  you know I think the most telling thing  about you is come on maybe there's  nothing down here it's the little girl  you got chained up in the basement we're  taking her with us all right you're free  come with us  [Applause]  sooner or later someone's I'll come  looking for you too  there's still time  or a bad  [Music]  don't sit here and tell me you don't  wish you never went down those stairs  [Music]  so you guys gonna kill us or  you